découvrir la ville de montfort l'amaury
autrement voilà le but de l'esc est game
en extérieur développé par la maison du
tourisme et du patrimoine et
l'entreprise quest ix au cette enquête
policière en deux parties la tombe 107
et le retour du pire au corps axes
peuvent se jouer de 2 à 6 joueurs le jeu
se fait en autonomie donc les gamers
démarre chez nous et puis ils peuvent se
promener ils ont des indices sur leur
smartphone et ils peuvent jouer donc
dans la ville tout seul à l'heure qu'il
qu'il souhaite et au moment qu'ils
souhaitent
ce jour là trois soeurs sont venues
jouer direction le cimetière pour la
première étape on a une liste d'énigmes
et on se répartit chacun les énigmes et
donc chacune en prend une est comme ça
en gagne du temps et on fait on a six
énigmes à faire pour terminer l'étape
après quelques minutes yasmine vient de
trouver une énigme
j'ai trouvé le résultat c'était une
image il faut que je trouve le métier
est là du coup j'ai gagné deux étoiles
j'ai gagné aussi un indice une image que
je pourrai réutiliser tout à l'heure une
fois l'étape terminée une autre énigme
apparaît et vous emmène dans un autre
lieu du centre ville vous devez résoudre
les enquêtes policières en moins de 80
minutes pour des enfants ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui sont pas évidentes se
retrouvant par le glissement ses frères
ce jeu s'adresse aussi bien aux
touristes qui souhaiteraient découvrir
la ville comme montfortois ça peut
s'adresser aux habitants montfort en
leur faisant découvrir d'autres une
autre façon de voir leur ville et
surtout qui lève les yeux pas venue a
beaucoup beaucoup de choses cachées que
les gens ne voient pas pour participer à
ce jeu il suffit donc de télécharger
l'application quest ix au sur votre
smartphone de payer 5 euros par joueur
et de trouver la clé de l'énigme